for the next 15 minutes I'm going to
talk about myself and my role briefly
and then a few startups that I've gone
through for special ed talked about
myself so I don't repeat that basically
was born and educated in Korea a
bachelor's degree from soul legend
University and then came to state for my
masters and PhD after graduation I spent
a lot of work in Silicon Valley first
work for Intel about 12 years after that
a few startups and the general manager
at GE and I currently am working for the
ls corporation as a certain value
equation over here basically I have both
technology and business experiences be
cooperation and small startups hardware
and software so whatever you name it I
have all the good taste on that right ok
so two more advertisement slide I want
to talk about my cooperation that I'm
working for right now FS is a top 13th
largest corporation in Korea in terms of
asset we are technology manufacturing
cooperation providing a broad range of
equipment for power improv technologies
our target markets are smart and green
especially in a pack and Amir markets
and at a high level we have five
business units start from cable and
cable systems and then we call
industrial systems division which is
making smart grid power and alterations
and we have three more additional
business unit the materials and consumer
life energy side and machinery and
equipment combining all of them last
year our revenue was
34 billion dollars which is about five
times bigger for a gross for the last
ten years my operation is called the LSS
bo this is corporate strategy team or
corporate venture we are looking for new
technologies to be a leader of
next-generation power employed
technologies we are looking for both and
hardware ends of the earth for example
smart grid soft ears and advanced
materials are some of the example areas
that we are looking for our cooperation
LS is known to have a strong partnership
management philosophy it means both
internal teamwork and external
collaboration with that we try to work
with potential partners here through the
joint ventures mnas that's the mission
that I have here in Alaska scenario
office with that let me talk on today's
main topic which is the Korea and its
ecosystem for the Silicon Valley
startups to start with that let's talk
about Korea business environment first
from my last work at GE I was able to
get these statistics like Korea is about
one-fourth of California in terms of
land side the thirty percent more
population so it is very densely
populated country and in terms of the
technology infrastructures from my
healthcare experience I was able to get
this information three times more
hospitals four times more bad and one
hundred percent EMR which is electronic
medical record penetrations it means we
are digitized in terms of digital DNA we
are well advanced of other markets for
example for the broadband penetration we
are but every light 96
and even we are trying to deploy fiber
optics to the home and with that an
average in terms of household average
connection speed we are like 200 times
faster than us so we are definitely
early adapters what about government
government are keep pushing toward the
new technologies and encouraged to adopt
a new technology into the market for
example for healthcare they spend over 1
billion dollars for last couple of years
through the many pilot project and this
is kind of the technology that we're
talkin these days here as mobile health
or healthcare IT technologies so they're
definitely government is pushing toward
the aldi markt spot what it means to the
Silicon Valley startups you know
basically to point that I just mentioned
early adapter market and the government
support plus engineering talent let me
add one more axis which is the there are
many global top-tier corporations like
LS is one of the examples as AP to be
but there are definitely other
cooperation that you know Samsung and LG
RP to see with this additional global
top-tier corporations and two other axes
that I just described both of them are
working for let's say start up the
Silicon Valley startup companies they
can either directly manage all through
the partnership they will together and
utilize this system to build a reference
site first and then you know remember
this reference ID can potentially spill
into big market down to Japan and China
as you can see those areas within three
hours flight from career so that's how
we look at the Korea ecosystem huh and
how to utilize this for your startups in
Silicon Valley
for the next three examples I'm going to
show how I did utilize this ecosystems
first around 2005 time frame after Intel
i co-founded a company which is mobile
Weymouth's chick sep company for the
smartphones at that time like what
you're talking these days is the
cloud-based cloud competing but at that
time wireless communication was the the
buzzword for startups it was one of the
area that everybody was going after
because the Wi-Fi was wide spreading to
the PCs and the appliance every year
that's why Intel and and few other
companies try to extend first of all the
success of Wi-Fi toward the longer range
of communications so that longer range
of wireless communication is called
wimax so that's why I founded this
mobile WiMAX company and at that time
try to address the need of the
integrated low-power chipsets for the
cell phones now three point that was
that make about these starves first this
chipset is very complicated observe so
we need the skilled engineers to design
the chipset second point you know
chipset pigeons more there is very like
heavy capital intensive business model
spending hundred million dollars before
hitting the market is often seen that's
a second factor and third one different
from like Asia versus the US in a
Buddhist thinking that this market was
too early even the 3g deployment was not
fully done and talking about 4G and
mobile wimax and LTE was too early so I
had some dilemma of the having a early
market
and you know heavy capital intensive
business model and how to survive out of
this environment so my strategy at the
time was to employ a you know Crocs
mother through the partnership in Korea
and APEC countries so I have a my team
members at the low as small as possible
in Silicon Valley and that design was
then manufacturers in Taiwan and then
use the modules modern manufacturers in
Korea and Japan and that merger goes
into phone system manufacturers like
Samsung and the carriers SKT and Kiki so
all these partners that I was trying to
fully utilize from the clear side and
one more thing was the partner company
in Korea was helping together to build
the reference side in an Asian market so
that's how was I I was able to control
the bond rate and sustain longer than
other competitors it is unfortunate that
the mobile wimax lost batter against LTE
but you know no matter what we are able
to exit to the local market because that
has a special military application of it
so even as an exit this partnership an
ecosystem in Korea was very valuable to
us so next example was on the mobile
software company because I spent too
much of time and energy on heavy capital
intensive model and then I switch my
interest to the software side and
software is very similarly with the
other a chipset Asia was faster in terms
of move in terms of market than us so we
look at you know the mobile software
side and we have our belief that this
software will grow as a smartphone
market is growing globally so we start
out on the mobile software company but
one thing in terms of strategy we didn't
know how long is going to take and how
it's going to unfold in
terms of market development so our focus
of this company was a giant technology
platform so we don't know what's going
to happen so we try to make a very
strong technology foundation first and
two and then integrate payment and track
and manage and other value-added
services over time with the market loss
so that was my target and in terms of
growth strategy as i said the market
were spread out globally like for us
back in 2020 and 929 2009 us was just
gaining traction in the mobile payment a
mobile banking side but at the same time
curry anemia create Korea and the Emir
markets are already past that point and
they're looking for other value-added
applications like mobile changes and
mobile ticketing so many others are you
know value-added applications so looking
at the different stages of market my
strategy growth strategy was first
utilized Korea as a a chasm development
and then build a first initial reference
then after that i strengthened the
platform through the 13 more APEC
country engagement so by the end of the
13 reference site in a pack we were
ready to use that as a silver bullet
point for us market penetration in fact
it did work out well so after that APEC
reference ID we are able to penetrate
into big financial institutions in us so
we quickly grow too large side and that
repeated the procedures for the
value-added applications over time
finally at the end of day we sold our
company to one of the large software
company in u.s. okay third example is
little different from the other two
this is how I was able to come up with a
pittance mother from working with the
teams and the environment in Korea in
two thousand seven ish Stanford came up
with the fantastic invention which is
the robot time on the windows let me
show that okay this is the one of your
fellow up each teach students a Stanford
came up with this invention and in fact
he is now teaching at MIT and he and I
sit down to discuss and come up with the
business mother out of this you know
this is great invention then you know
how we can make money out of this that's
kind of been smaller the we talked about
many different technologies around this
robot systems among them this day foot
was very interesting point which this
one gives the strong gripping at one
hand on the other hand it can easily
release it that's why you can move
around so with that point on we try to
come up we came up with the a gripping
application so same kind of get Coldfoot
tape was an underneath of these two area
and when you attach to the glass and
with little bit of a tangential force it
gives a strong addition so that means
this technology can be somehow
applicable to the handling of glasses so
that's how much we are able to come up
with but then you know what can we do
with this it that we didn't know
anything about beyond that this is kind
of ideas and experimental this is one of
the stamp of that that we made out of
this and you can see that if and the
addition is so hard and you can even do
like
a rotational movement without dropping
the glasses and you can see this the
other point is that when whenever you
have a strong gripping forces then it's
hard to drop or release the point of
handling glasses you have two things
together strong gripping at one hand the
other is you have to release easily
otherwise you know you cannot handle
these glasses pretty well so with this
much of information from Stanford and we
spent days and night and to come up with
the viable commercial in his mother out
of this we made so many trucks trip to
Korea and why the Korea because
similarly with the other 12 cases
robotics was a little bit early in US
market at the same time Korean
government was pushing pretty hard to
adopt the new technologies including
robotics so that's why we may so many
trips over there and the government then
the universities they have a lot to
arrange a meeting with corporations so
we met the LG and Samsung many times and
we found that one of their LCD
manufacturing process something called
ODF was in fact and used in the actual
lines what it does is you have to glass
plate and in the later stage of process
within the vacuum they assembled
together so basically the upper guys
need to come in and rotate up and push
push it down to assemble both upper and
lower classes together so from many
meetings we found that this is actually
happening in the air to the process and
we were able to replace the existing the
system called EST which is electrostatic
chuck which is better in a sense that so
many problems
and the electric always happens all
these glasses were dropped in in a
broken and the other you know
disadvantage was this electricity which
is induced to use the graphing has
potential damage on the circuitry the
glasses so our technology was found that
as a good potential advantage rich lot
of this market sorry okay the point here
is you know how I was able to utilize
the Korean ecosystems to come up with
the business models never go into
details of the the last in startups just
for the next one or two minutes let me
talk about thou the one of the
technology hub in Korea and the startups
over there hang your tech novelli is
about 10 miles south of Seoul Gangnam
which has 700 local stellar companies
they have many offices there including
at nap which is the security software
company and the solid and KakaoTalk that
you are pretty much aware of today I'm
going to talk about solid why because I
believe this is one of the exemplary
starter companies from Korea and like
Sir companies here the engine repeated
PhDs founded this company and their
focus was on technology and after six
years of the hard work they were able to
go to IPO in the Curia grab market which
is the nasty given which is we call
Kosta and after that they're working on
the global extensions and with the solid
technology foundations with the half of
the their employees by 154 to 50 70
their engineers and half of them are
holding advanced degrees
among their 14 years of the financial
tart I just want to point out this two
thousand five and six which is the
distinction between domestic and
overseas so after success for IPO they
invest more on to global expansions in
terms of R&D after five or six years of
the more spending versus set trade
market from Korea side we were
successfully out of this dilemma and
came to the global expansions from 2012
last year they came back bigger than
before more importantly the
characteristics of revenue the overseas
market is try to servicing the domestic
market side and as a result they are
doing the global business in many
different areas the point that I try to
come up with the this startup is same
and similar in my case I utilize Korea
ecosystem from here from tercanbury
perspective in that their case they
founded the company in Korea that
utilized the early adopter markets and
the fast-growing wireless communication
markets over there to build their
technology barriers and with that they
were able to come up to the global
market and now now with the solid
foundations they're able to play
globally so that's in a sense that we
share the same fundamental in a past and
how to utilize the Korean ecosystems I
think Brian will talk about more of this
kind of opportunities and similar areas
thank you very much oh why don't you
have a seat and let's uh change over and
i'll change the slides and ask Brian to
give a few comments
do you want to use the PDF version of
the PowerPoint version okay i guess i've
got the PDF up so there we go okay
floors yours thank you so i have a quick
quick intro about formation eight and
then how we're working with korea it's a
it's a it's a very special day for me
back home at Stanford and I'm telling
you why you should work my home country
Korea I think Jin already did a great
job telling you i'll just add couple
more things really quick confirmation 8
we are we just raised a pretty good size
of fun and we're a pretty new fund in
the valley we invest in early-stage
growth companies in mostly IT sectors
but some other sectors as well because
I'll tell you why we just consider most
of the big industries as tech industry
now and we invest in most US companies
we do seek for opportunities out of us
as well but then you know most of the
companies we have here we work with them
help them go get bigger mostly with asia
market including Korea and I'll focus
more on Korea today and we invest about
520 million in the companies and work
with them so I thought I would just
introduce the team of formation it to
you you know we it's like you know like
Jim Joe and myself pretty much started
formation 8 we have a special adviser a
good friend Gideon gym and Gideon myself
have like Korea are Koreans or Korean
Americans so you know we naturally have
to work with Korea Joe started on
palantir we have a lot of Stanford
network here Joe is also Stanford alum
Gideon as well so we build companies we
help companies before and we decided to
team up together and just do that under
one platform so we're very excited and
Gideon definitely helps a lot in the
process so what we believe that
formation 8 is I think this light and
next slide will tell you it's um we
think there was a very big couple you
know like like waves in the valley
started with the old enterprise for sure
and then
there were some telecom wave and then
most recently we think there was like
really fun time with the consumer wave
we still believe there's going to be a
lot happening there but we do think the
peak is probably like past the next wave
we are very excited about is what we
call smart enterprise I won't talk about
it too much detail but it's it's um you
know it's all the data and software that
is really transforming all the existing
big industries and we think that's where
most disruption you know destructive
things are going to happen trillion
dollar business opportunities we think
so we're in that one so and I've
mentioned it earlier we just think that
there's no more education healthcare
finance energy sector as a silo sector
we just think that this world is now
changing so fast every single big
industry is going to get it's already
getting disrupted by engineer lead
companies software a big data a
different type of approach you have to
think out of box that is all getting
applied to majority of the industries
right now so we did invest in most of
those companies these are all companies
our partners got involved before and now
so we think this is a big theme going on
now i'll just talk more about now like
asia and then korea right so again this
is how we work at formation eight again
neck at the core you know like
innovation we think still happens in the
valley but then we think about the
growth of all these technology companies
it's it's hard to think you know things
without Asia right and you know so we
have office in Singapore Korea China to
support our company's going there
establishing partnerships selling more
of their products in solution and it's
it's working very well I'll just give
you some examples in us when we have to
when we deal with an energy IT company
that they need to sell more partner with
the utility in us it's very challenging
it's a great market but you have to deal
with at least couple hundred utilities
who all have different perspective we
have different decision making process
and it's so it's hard to scale very fast
compared to that in China there's only
two pretty much utility is the bigger
one is state grid
definitely not easy to establish a
partnership but if you'd know how to do
it if you really put the effort and you
get it you can see the numbers you
basically get like two-thirds of China
as your customers in the Korea has only
one utility as well which is even better
probably again it's not like easy to
establish a partnership with them but
it's totally worth going after it and
there are ways to get it done this is
another one this is totally outdated but
um you heard we probably heard about I
mean whatsapp you know getting acquired
right but other than what's up there's
we chat in China as you probably know
right cacao and lying from Korea and
couple more like you know keep coming up
but let's just even just take a look at
line we chat and cacao and this is again
like very outdated right so it's
probably safe to say getting close to
double of this number but when you see
it just those three mobile platforms
together they have well again they had
900 million users all together it's
definitely much much much more than
billion they have like seven billion
daily messages going across the platform
just like just only line have like
1,000,000,000 sticker transactions going
on so when you think about this and then
if you are already in a mobile startup
company or if you're planning to work on
that that type of company it's probably
not a good idea if you're going to
ignore these potential partners they
could really change the game they bring
you instant distribution and they're
actively looking for the right partners
they are here in the valley so it's it's
a great moment for you to think about
this I think Jen already talked about
why Korea is a very exciting place it's
you know so i won't go through the
detail but i actually even found out
with my team that oh there's actually
like a couple more exciting things about
korea it's a very dynamic country you
know it's the best mobile you know
penetration best infrastructure for that
so if you have a app or if you have a
platform korea is a very good test space
market you can get feedbacks people are
very very picky about things and as you
know like if you look at you know me
know if you look at the iphone if you
look at the i know i pad seventy eighty
percent of the
components are pretty much coming from
like Korea right and the critical ones
so it is a very interesting country
itself what I want to talk more is this
this is our model as well so as I
mentioned we work with Korea China and
Singapore South East Asia Korea is a
very good hub for that activity right so
if you're planning to go into Asia in
general I do strongly recommend thinking
about working first with Korea and
that's what we're doing as well because
Korea if you talk there's two things one
if you talk to all the leadership at
Samsung and LG and like LS and many of
these corporations they are not trying
to find the next solution in Silicon
Valley for korean market they're all
trying to go global right they know that
korean market is small they're actively
going into China they're actually going
to it India Africa make most of the part
of the world so if you can strike a very
important partnership with them they
will also take you to other part of the
world right so Korea is a great partner
for because of that second is you
probably heard about kpop right Korean
like pop industry and all that becoming
quite hot it is even trying to come to
us these days I guess but it's not just
the pop music only it used to be japan
as a trendsetter before in asia now i
think it's really korea so if you talk
to the young folks at china they are
really trying to see the fashion the
food the culture coming out from korea
that's why the kpop is also getting a
lot of boost so it's a great partner if
you can leverage that in your business
if you are in the media entertainment or
a certain mobile business think about
partnering with kpop or k culture kind
of you know folks because then you get
additional you know angle when you go
into China or Southeast Asia so again
this is some good numbers again this is
also our data is 2011 but look at the
growth and that is not slowing down it
will slow down at some point I can say
but at least for the next couple years I
think it's going to just like continue
this growth so think about a seriously
it's um it's a big wave over there I
thought I would just give you some
example as well we you know we've been a
you know big investor in oculus I know
if you heard about it but it's a virtual
reality company just got acquired by
Facebook
it was a very exciting company to work
with and I won't get into too much
detail because it's still you know and
in the process of you know the
acquisition but i would tell you this in
the success of oculus there was there
were many many critical components that
was coming from Asia you know in the as
we already talked about iphone and ipad
the component part oculus had critical
partnership in Korea that enabled many
of their technologies that is one second
was I was also deeply involved in the
partnerships and for the virtual reality
for oculus there were many many
significant partners lining up in Asia
and some of those are game studio some
of them are movie theater chains but
when you see the size of the business
they can bring it's probably like eight
to 10 X compared to the biggest like
game studios in US you know eight to 10
x or even like 20 30 x in terms of the
movie theater like movie kind of
contents distribution education market
that further the VR ecosystem we had no
doubt that Asia would play a critical
role and that really supported office in
general couponing is an interesting
thing I invested in kupang is a Korean
company it's the ecommerce you know I
would say just I won't go too deep but
it's an e-commerce company I just wanted
to talk about coupon because for some of
you who might say well I do want to
probably work with Korea but Korea
market again I also said it career
market is small but depending on your
business Korea market itself could give
you a big success because I think Jin
mentioned it's a very like density and
people use mobile a lot more than we do
over here and they're very used to you
know commerce and mobile commerce so
coupon is with just Korea market is way
over 1 billion dollar revenue today
right and it's just keep growing fast
and we still think there's a lot more
they can get with just career market
right so think about that too I just
thought it would be a nice you know
example to share this is my last slide
um this is well I think like gin was
talking a little bit about it Korea
again the reason why I really like you
know enjoy working with Korea's because
they're really trying hard you know it's
it's still
no time where they're like you know
evolving and learning but the Korean
government you know the people in Korea
they're just really trying hard to bring
up the ecosystem so I was honestly very
cautious whenever there was some of
these kind of you know initial plans but
after talking to the folks involved in
this cave alley plan which is about
building the Silicon Valley ecosystem in
Korea we might myself and my team
working with Korea decided to jump in
and really play a critical role in this
in this action again that is a one
actual Valley type place in Korea very
close to Seoul and all the top high-tech
companies including the line and cacao
type exciting companies they're pretty
much like moving into this area there
are a couple universities there which
also helps us the ecosystem what we're
trying to do here is to bring the global
perspective early on I told them I don't
want this to become like a Korea Korea
centric plan it has to adopt things from
Silicon Valley as soon as possible have
the people right people in the valley
which is not just all the koreans here
but folks at stanford folks around the
valley to get involved early on and help
out so we are bringing many friends and
you know great you know mentors around
the valley to participate and help out
but so if you are thinking about either
putting a smaller office in Korea or
actually start your company in Korea
free asian market you know k Valley is
also going to provide a lot of benefit
but we're trying to help get tell them
what are the practical benefits that
they should be giving right so this is a
start starting point I guess for Korea
but with our best to build it we are
exploring a lot of partnership with
Stanford so I hope you could participate
as well I think that's all I have great
lion thank you Jim lets lets us go back
up in all three of us now become a panel
Jim why don't you sit in the middle
Brian take the Farsi I'll sit over here
own while we're getting set let me ask
the first question so if you're an
entrepreneur and you're starting up a
company from zero you have zero
resources you've got to do things with
little or no money you're trying to
build your connections as you go along
it impresses me that most people would
think it's too hard to do things
globally early on that really growing
the startup company through this kind of
global partnership is like 10 times as
hard and ten times as risky water what
do you think are the challenges and how
do people overcome those challenges Jin
you go first and then Brian would you
take that sure okay you're up straight
right on that the operation from the
operation perspective it has a lot of
complexity and it's not that easy first
of all you have you need to talk to your
visas over here and whenever you are
saying that I'm going to have like
global operation together and they are
very true so yeah they said you're crazy
or not sometimes that but think about
this way one of my example was very
capital intensive business model for
example if you do it the newest only
normally hundred million dollars before
hitting any market inflection point was
quite quite popular at that time so with
the control at the burning rate and if
you have a strong partnership like in
overseas in my case because I was
educated over there I had context and
the government and other ecosystems are
fully supportive on that and with that
story behind that you know I was able to
work with the u.s. VCS and energy they
bought their ideas okay they bought the
ideas but then you actually got sorted
into the operations and had to manage it
you can only be in one place at the time
yes so there's another very interesting
story when I was working as a CTO for
mobile software company and the people
often ask me where I leave where is my
home address you know my typical answer
was the 18 which is my airplane seat
number so I need to be in the air always
I think that's quite typical I don't
know is changing so fast and these days
I don't know what's going to happen but
back then even on until like
22 12 everybody was traveling from us to
India and Korea so it wasn't that issue
yeah okay Brian what do you think about
this I mean you're looking at it from
the investor side right what are the
things that you would say you're the key
points that a company would bring into
the sort of global aspect that you would
look at is for success well I I think um
I'll give you give you an answer first
that you're very familiar with which is
um you do need the right partner you
need you do need the right partner that
you can really trust and this is not
easy right so that's why many people
talk about it but it's not easy to
establish I think first of all you know
you have to be very open-minded and it's
anyway this it's also the interesting
timing right now I guess it's it's
probably not you're probably not
thinking enough if you are not
considering Asia as a place to go at
this moment right another thing I would
say is like more allies is critical
that's why I actually that's why we
started formation eight right i mean i
was i would have to say like that that's
why you should come to formation hain
right it's that's why we started it we
thought that you know it's a timing when
companies should go to Asia and really
work with Asia but it is hard it is hard
as you know you mentioned i know it's
and so it's not just like an
entrepreneur job we cannot expect the
entrepreneur to like resolve that alone
so what we try to do is lease is this
entrepreneur someone we can work with
right is he willing to or she willing to
trust us and really work with us then we
have to do our part right so and the
good thing is many of these you know
potential partners in Asia they're all
coming here as well now right so it's
much better time I mean when when 10
years ago and we were when I was doing
with my team in a different way it was
quite tough you know like because we had
to have genset how to be travel
ourselves do all these conference calls
the good thing is as you know like
everyone Tencent right Samsung and many
many more they are here as well so it's
a better time but you have to put that
effort and find more allies from the VC
side from the corporate side can I ask
about how long you were actually
invested in oculus before Facebook
bought them out ah well we first got
involved about a year and a half ago and
then a significant investment was about
six months ago were you doing things for
them to get help them get into the Asian
market yes yes I mean that was our
thesis when we actually made our first
investment we saw amazing well first of
all I was amazing team and vision and
then our team just not just myself but
we have a team in Asia we all agreed
that we can make significant impact
together with this company so we helped
them setting up a career office we hired
the people together we again as I
mentioned we started talking to most of
the network we had in Asia for
entertainment education you know all
those you know industries we were
starting to line up them and again I
can't tell more detail but the component
partnerships was critical for this
company and they were doing very well
but definitely like they could take some
support so yeah I mean we like when you
do something between Asia and us you
have to work with your investor and with
your allies almost as I building a
company together it cannot be through
just introductions it cannot be just
threw some reference and that's what we
did with oculus okay great let's open
the floor questions from the floor if
not I have one more of let me get let me
go first then so Brian the arrow goes
from Silicon Valley to Asia in your
picture at what point do you see arrows
from say Southeast Asia going to write
other places in Asia and the US um well
well I think there is already an arrow
we are actually investing in also a
couple companies in Asia and then we
help them go to other part of Asia and
also to us right it's just just the fact
is the truly disruptive companies like
the platform type approach companies are
just coming out more here but if you
look at certain type of business models
actually Asia you know are actually like
doing you know quite better and they are
they have advantage which is there
closer to also now big market which is
China Southeast Asia so it's it's
happening it is happening I think that's
why we also trying to support them from
the ecosystem part because engineers and
and entrepreneurs they are very good
good people coming out from that market
it's just about can they get the support
so it's just taking a bit more time but
it's going very fast okay Jenna follow
up for you now so large high prestige
companies in Asia are not easy to work
with okay right how did you get through
and convince them that you were for real
okay well in a before my current job
well I was working for GE and GE we were
saying that has matrix organization and
is really tough to work and manage
within that environment and compared to
that you know for myself because I may
be educated then was able to speak
Korean but there is no difference in
terms of you know difficulty so working
with them the difference is basically
they are huge corporations decision the
matrix is all complicated you know
there's so many the parties involved in
there and you need to get the there or
agreement together so at a high level
I'm not saying it's not necessary more
difficult over there but nonetheless
there are some differences they're
definitely one of example is that the HR
perspective you know not like working
with the the corporation letter per se
but their HR policy is very strict there
is like it allows that you cannot easily
let the people go so there are other
side that is little different from what
you are used to here in Silicon Valley
so I think that's more challenging
difficult rather than working with them
in a corporate cultures perspective ok
go ahead
sort of thinking through what I just
heard in both of your presentations and
value proposition of considering Korea
as sort of the launching pad into other
markets into Asian markets and I'm
wondering for how long that value
proposition is going to remain if there
is really a compelling one today as it
appears to me it's Korea's acting is
like the middleman and and what would be
the motivation to to work with that
middleman is it is it the infusion of
capital is a capital that one cannot
access here in the US is it human and
facility resources that would be too
expensive to recreate here but what is
you know it succinctly what what is the
value proposition for for choosing South
Korea as a middleman I can take it first
before I forget okay as I pointed out in
my presentation I was writing through
sorry about that I was trying to make
that point clear first the Korea is very
early market and they have tendency of
try the new technology so on the other
end for like circularly startups we are
betting on the new technology in early
stage you know of the market and
ironically many visas are here and
captured as saying that we need wait for
the right timing sometimes especially
when you're dealing with the heavy
capital intensive business model will
say so you need somehow survived that
gaps okay so in that perspective Korea
and their ecosystem is really one of the
strong advantage for you to come up with
your test cases as a reference point and
also you can sustain with the control
bond rate for a few years until the
actual global size market is taking off
sometimes you know it doesn't take off
you know but you have longer let's say
one way to wait for the big
we've so in that perspective Korea has
one of the excellent ecosystems okay you
know when I when we have a portfolio
company right to your point saying okay
now I want to go into Asia right I was
specially China at the end like how do I
do that there are many reasons why we
first get to talk about like okay should
we do something in Korea first obviously
the most important thing for now is I
think like after Israel and the valley
here Korea has really good talented
engineers so if you need to do some
localization work in a decent way and
you want good designing aspect of it
hard-working you know trustworthy I
think Korea has a very unique value
proposition for now right more and more
engineers are you know getting into the
startup environment so you get good pool
of people like that second is again like
when we have what if you want to test
something in China or south southeast
asia it'sit's compared to us it might be
probably more straightforward but it's
still a pretty broad kind of market
sector that market that you have to like
work on Korea that the strength is again
as I said people are very dynamic and
they the word of mouth is just like
pretty fantastic right so if you have a
service and you have some of the people
in like young young folks especially in
Korea to try it out they do give you a
pretty decent feedback you know and and
and good ones right it's really
meaningful one so before you go to China
and we drop it and drop it in like you
know Singapore in other places it's a
good test bed for that reason the last
thing I probably over dimension is
Samsung LG like Hyundai Motor's all
these companies happen to be you know I
happen to have their headquarters in
Korea right those folks if you sit down
with them again as I mentioned they're
all about going global so if you talk to
a Chinese company that's the probably
the right partner for you for just China
because they have top priority first
acing their business in China but if you
talk to folks in Korea they care about
korean market but they have already
pretty good position so they can help
you like this but then they'll say okay
how can we work with you to launch like
two months from now
in China and then three months later in
Indonesia when you are aligned like with
them it works much better so that's why
you know and I don't know how long this
will go I honestly like I hope they
don't lose that kind of momentum if they
do I think they will get into a serious
problem you know even looking at some of
the period of time that Japan had to go
through so at least they're trying right
now so I do think the Obama is jumping
in should my own kind of take on this
notice that in this it's implied that
the entrepreneur has global perspective
okay and that you're dealing with
somebody whose view of Asia is not just
one country but of a global strategy
where you're going to go in multiple
markets eventually I think that's really
important and it's one of the things
that i really hope comes through from
this course Asia markets are important
individually but what's really important
is being able to develop the skills to
be flexible from one to another okay you
had a question us about the engineering
talents and the interference in Korea
because i had that like green my journal
start up on someone doing a salad is not
something that's very attractive
youngsters because it's more operator
joy light of the tribe or stand by the
corporation so how is it is well Posada
attract has enjoyed a more to meet other
entrepreneurs in Korea yeah well I won't
say I won't say as I completely
different now all right it's still I
would say probably seventy eighty
percent of parents would be very mad if
the kid says I'm gonna i got into
samsung but I'm not going to take that
I'm gonna join the startup I think
they'll get in serious trouble I saw
many we back to me so I got
entrepreneurs like that it is changing
though right it is changing because
because I think this is a big challenge
to groups like Samsung and LG and others
because it's not any more attractive
place right young people now in Korea
are mean they still have that pressure
but they are really like finding a place
where they can be happy and they want to
innovate things actually if you even
talk
to some many young people even at these
like you know toboi conglomerates
they're very innovative thinkers but
then when they feel when they understand
that oh but this environment i am like
it's not going to support my ideas many
of them are actually leaving at this
time i would say there's still small
number of Engineers and and you know
young people in Korea that would say I'm
going to start a start-up right that's
still like in a big problem but getting
better the exciting part is if there's a
very established fun startup coming from
the valley for example and then they say
we want to have a local team and so then
there are many good engineers that would
like to jump into that so what I'm
trying to do a lot is helping that part
because I think that will really help
critical system more fundamentally
because we tell many on engineers in
Korea like hey you don't have to start a
company it's like the government push is
not about just you doing a start-up now
it's actually bad if you're not ready to
do it but get into like an awesome you
know like a you know company when
they're opening up office in Korea learn
how they build a company when you're
ready then like go out and start your
own so we are doing a lot of that we
have many you know as I said we invest
mostly newest companies we help them set
up companies in Asia and Korea including
Korea that's when we go after the best
engineers and hoe and we try to tell
them look like this will be a great
opportunity for you because if you can
learn and then you say like hey I'm now
ready to do my own stuff we're happy to
back you right so it's still not like
here but I think it's not just the good
thing is it's not about the students
changing their mind anymore only I think
it'll naturally happen because the
conglomerates in Korea are not doing a
good job keeping their place as a sexy
place right so it's it's gonna it's
going in the right direction you're also
looking at companies here so people have
already made an international jump right
correct you know that's one thing that's
a big difference I saw some Wow all over
the place you go first I might ask you a
question
so the book on ecosystems as rain force
and I think most of us are edit pictures
good friend of mine how much do you
think the ecosystem is artificial or
will because of the 97 billion dollars
pledged by Korean government and the
second question I have really I'm not as
smart as all of the art can't spend my
career on Wall Street when so my
question is is there a really a
liquidity event for a lot of these
companies the Korean stock too there is
a bunch of barriers can you live so
thirsteee about the ecosystem right I
know that yeah to what extent is
government intervention something that
will really created something
sustainable i think is probably a better
way of looking at artificial or not
money is real yeah but okay I think he's
a really great question stand now let me
give you another example that US
government Obama health care they tried
pull I put in a lot of moneys for the
connected health kids and all the smart
smart grid you know smart meters they
put a lot of initial money's in there
and now by now if the market is not
taking off then would you say the same
things is artificial or not my point
here is that when whenever you work on
the new technology in new markets
there's always a failures and continuous
assists in mindset is there that's much
more important so from my own experience
by the way I had most of my startups in
Silicon Valley and I you try to utilize
the Korea side to make a growth in you
know different ways here and there
sometimes like mobile wimax they call it
as a web low government tried to push it
pretty hard to make a global standard
and in fact it came it came as a global
standard called 802 that 16 ye so for
that they put a lot of money in there
eventually market didn't take off you
know that they lost battle against LTE
so you know not nonetheless seen a
government that has their intention try
to keep working on it to keep pushing
and in high as kind of a very basic
level question about this so what kind
of money is this what sort of government
money is there if a company is trying to
locate and ponyo techno Valley or elk
and K Valley also what kind of strings
does it come with hmm okay yes transfer
okay you have your own yeah so I can go
first um uh I mean you would probably
already know what type of money that is
there's so many right i mean they have a
lot many many policies or many mean if
you come we'll give you this if you come
we can match if you get a funding will
match you we can match you with five
times now talking nine times in korea or
something like that comes with many
strings I think that's also changing
though I think that they're learning
that the way they have been doing is
really not working unfortunately I still
think it's not really completely
different yet right so so what I what we
all we say is even to the entrepreneurs
is like well first of all you should not
rely on that right like it's but it's
good to have thing right and when we
have a chance to talk to the
government's the same thing we say you
know I think the government should be
like more like um you know like more
like a referee like a referee rather
than like the actual coach just just
give us the right environment to play
right and the ones who do well we'll
survive the ones who you know don't do
well or do some bad things just just
make sure you get that but don't try to
say like this is a way to do go and
we'll we'll give you more I know it's
really hard for the government when
they're like very eager to do it but I
think that's to me that is what we tell
them so I would say oh and it's
unfortunate to say this but I think like
bulk of it is still probably artificial
but you know because we know their
intention right and that's why I think
we cannot just look at the government we
should say ok when the government is
acting like that it's a great timing how
can we contribute as well and hopefully
help them it's not easy but that's why
asking a lot of you know folks from
Korea and Asia in the valley to kind of
like do that as a give back nothing try
to support really quick on your second
one yes Korea market itself is probably
still not a sexy exit market I think
they are really thinking about it but
Asia in general is a very attractive
place that's why we do work a lot with
Korea not for the exit like hopefully
the exit but a great place to grow but
then like as you know like these these
folks in China even Southeast Asia
they're buying companies had pretty
interesting in evaluation Korea not yet
right but um but I would say like that
should not like discourage you like
thinking about Asia in general all right
so Jim let me ask you a follow-up so in
terms of what you would see is an
appropriate exit strategy for companies
that LS gets involved with are these
things that LS group would want to
acquire or are they really things that
you would be happy to see them go public
or what because we are a corporate at
that we are looking for our like asserts
its strategic close together so you know
as I pointed out in and then one of my
slide you know joint venture is one
example and they acquisition from the
start perspective that means their exit
opportunities for us so we are open for
that going into IPO by in you know
independent a little bit we have some
distance from our corporate perspective
but no okay anything what sorry really
cook onda I just want to say if you are
thinking about or already working on a
company I think what we like to do is
always is um again going into age you
need many allies right so usually what
we recommend is work with many of these
strategic partners but don't necessarily
have them as the major like a you know
like partner that would really drive
your strategy or direction so we do
involve many of these strategic partners
like like alas or singtel or you know
ten cent to even be an investor if they
want and then establish a partnership
but then that's when we make sure we
bring the right financial investors
together and friends
help them drive the company in the right
way that usually works very well yeah
good thank you you know you're Korean
Valley and you know Silicon Valley's and
identity is a track that talk talent
from all over the world I was wondering
what percentage in Korean valley are the
foreign companies or foreign people are
they all Korea but no so that's why I
completely agree with you and that's why
ok Valley is just like getting started
and when the people in Korea started
that they definitely had to first reach
out to their their best high tech
companies around right like Korea so
right now the image I had those are all
Korean companies right so when I when we
like I'm information it started talking
to them we said well you know if if if
we could get involved we would like to
make sure our strategy gets implemented
right and our strategy was this should
not continue in this way right because
then it will become a very nice town for
Korea but it won't really become a
meaningful place so we said you know in
next year right when we show this like
picture it should have probably at least
half of the companies as Chinese us you
know hopefully many like branches from
Silicon Valley top you know IT companies
and I told them you should really give
incentives to those companies and we
were happy to link link those to you so
yes I mean I'm with you it's it's that
is the mission right if that doesn't
happen then it'll be another failure
look good let's go ahead I saw your hand
first yeah you said it's so very good
market for early adopters um I mean how
big is their calling our people rich
enough to buy expensive products just
like that or and I have a statistical
number of that globally I love it from
GE operation is about 1% rock the clear
market is global compared to global size
is between one to five percent but that
is like a number 13 country in the whole
world yes okay so the American companies
over there like apple or any of the
Western companies for example you were
talking your Samsung LG and
and I or how about four door you know
any of the Western companies how is
their presents are they comfortable
enough to do business or like can delay
be big Giants over there 20 like with
the locals compete with the locals like
okay that since again you know I have
done to my work from g perspective there
are many branches and sales office over
there in Korea again the like Sears
numbers for the global cooperation
perspective is around one to five
percent and that number itself is huge
from for example GE the korean market is
surplus about two billion dollars so you
know still comfortable size and it's
growing it's not like they go over again
like other korean competitors not often
seen over there but the marcasite is
good Poor Dad education if you're doing
education company like with cream market
I think you can go IPO right they will
be a good enough customer for you to go
like IPO it's a like spent like
expenditure per like capital Korea's
like like way up there right on
education part if you look at some like
mobile game companies right that
launched early on on like a cow platform
at all you see them by making like 1
million a day right um that that's like
you know I go that can tell you you know
how I'll active there i mean the
commandos I want to maybe you have more
recent info than I do but a couple of
years ago I was putting together a
presentation and I remember that Korea
had like the number 13 besides economy
in the world but in terms of R&D
spending Korea was like number three or
number four na it was remarkably a lot
of money being spent on technology
development this is also in the growth
phase right you know useful and many hey
I mean Qualcomm micra so I'm in Google
many many of those right like folks were
more familiar here they do choose Korea
many times as they're kind of like erd
like location because again same thing
they get really big you know good
feedbacks it's a pretty strategic
location as well from any other
locations so it's definitely in a place
to your point you know that is working
that way
okay go ahead on social entrepreneurship
that there's no service that targets and
benefits Korean population but if it
didn't have a business model what are
the resources were on day we are gonna
look at this in a subsequent week of the
series honestly it's social
entrepreneurship is a very interesting
topic where you have to consider
elements of entrepreneurship meaning
startup company formation in order to
come up with a sustainable business
model but the big difference between
social entrepreneurship and for-profit
startup companies is that by definition
you don't have the same kind of exit you
know you want to build something and go
it and make it go IPO or sell it to
somebody isn't really something you have
in the social entrepreneurship space so
typically you do have to find different
resources who are doing impact investing
or whatever for that now i'm not sure
what kind of yeah impact investing or
not be in korea um well I'm not the
expert for sure but I can tell you it's
still compared to here it's very early
stage so if you're looking for resource
it might be more challenging but in
terms of impact it could it could you
know be a good market because it's early
stage all right well you know they're
good amount of capital not easy to
access I think that's a problem they're
facing and they know that right so there
that's why i was saying they're changing
that they have good good programs they
have many VCS but you know I think we're
also talking about this into valid these
days right like we now pitch to the
entrepreneurs to the good ones right
because we have to tell them why you
should take our money because they know
the good ones I mean like you guys here
like money is commodity right you know
that so you want the value adding
partner to help you build your
billion-dollar company I think I'm just
saying like they're very good people and
very good you know VCS in Korea but for
like a you know a company to really go
to global and think
about bigger ideas and different ways to
do things I think that's a challenge of
that ecosystem so many entrepreneurs
don't necessarily pick that money so
that's that's the go-ahead similar
question many of the examples that you
both used in your presentations had a
lot to do with how Korea is a really
great supporting ecosystem for a growth
strategy and my question is well what
about the stage before that what about
the companies that are like Professor
dash that starting from Ground Zero and
can I kind of preface this I set him up
I told them I wanted to talk about
growth and you know basically this is
kind of the focus that we're using this
quarter is more on growth and exit than
it is on the actual formation having
said that and said that I set you up go
ahead such as the government subsidies
subsidies as well as this whole 4k
Valley formation and support of a more
collaborative startup ecosystem granted
is it more collaborative for the growth
strategy or would it be is it changing
in a sense that Koreans are are more now
more encouraged to be get innovating so
I mean really quit from my side is on
all the K Valley and you know some other
efforts we're putting is to support them
in the earlier stage hopefully to
generate more great entrepreneurs from
Korea or other countries entrepreneurs
starting to things in Korea I think that
will really help create go system in you
know anyway so that is all activities to
hopefully like support more
entrepreneurs in that stage right but I
would say like even if you are earlier
stage but it depends on the business
model if you are in like a mobile
business very specific mobile business
and you're like series a type very early
stage it might be better to actually
still go now to Korea and into China for
for even that early growth part right so
it all depends on the model yeah i mean
it's it's right now the ecosystem for
the early start upside is i would say
like this it's very very good if you
don't have to rely hundred percent on
the local people there so if
have a couple really good global like
supporters as investor or advisors and
then you go there and set up a company
there's a good ecosystem you can
leverage right because good job
government is positive about helping you
many people are trying to help they just
they just need some guidance right so if
you're looking for guidance in Korea
early early on you know probably still
not the best place to go but you know
yeah am I playing what are you saying so
I personally don't have a let's say very
start from scratch in Korea so I rather
start started my company here and then
try to utilize their equity some of
their so somehow you get funding from
feces over here for example and then you
bring that to the career to open up the
local branches over there then you can
find their good syndicate captain man is
over there pretty easily so from that
perspective arm I think there are good
size of captors and you know engineers
all the system that you can start with i
got a comment i'm an advisor to an
accelerator and soul and i think that
you see young people in Korea who are
really entrepreneurial and excited and
the system is not friendly to them in
terms of allowing them to grow that's
why this accelerator is looking at a
follow-on program to bring those some of
the successful companies here to the
valley and one of the reasons that I
wanted this discussion is because I
think this kind of international
approach to entrepreneurship may
actually kickstart a lot not the company
I may actually you know get things off
the ground to help entrepreneurs see
that there are opportunities that didn't
use to exist so anyway I wanted to say
that you have a question on energy
sector in Korea because I know that with
it being that you're well educated
country as a whole and having large
coastal population climate change would
have to be kind of at the forefront of a
lot of people's minds that the same time
it can be
risky business to get into instead of
showing your altima John not true okay
so any specific energy attack the day
you were thinking for example but sauron
anything you want talk about spirits
okay energy you know I'm looking at more
of like energy I eat like this market so
utilizing the IT tech man's with the
traditional like energy in terms of
optimize the whole loop like
transmissions and dissipations and
reading of the data's and you know
pumping back to your customers and
thinking of the big data's and you know
try to utilize those data as for the
enhancement of the overall descriptions
that that the idea is there definitely
and the government is pushing very hard
for that but but you know similarly to
hear the company cultures over there in
that sector is slow even though the
korea in general is faster than other
countries but between the different
verticals you know they're slower than
like the electronics and other consumer
side of it so it is taking some time but
you know it is growing that's one aspect
the other would think they were talking
in the inner side that I just described
is mostly softy aside the software
business in Korea is very very strange
and interesting and traditionally is
very much harder eccentric country and
the software was given for free that's
what their mindset is so if you try to
somehow get the mini like a revenue our
own a pure softer approach there is a
little bit of challenge to get over it
ok I can I can just add I mean you
remember Ginny's position is to do open
innovation out here for LS corporation
that gives a good message I think
because quick answers I think there's a
great opportunity because really quick
two reasons one is as gin
there's still hardware centric but they
are now recognizing the value of
software but then they also kind of know
that it's very hard for them to do it
right so I'm personally actively always
looking for like software engineers in
the valley putting the next solution
that could really you know disrupt the
energy sector but then they still need
to work with hardware vendors and
hardware you know system most of the
players in Korea for example Asia that's
their expertise right so you have a very
good partnership it is not easy but if
you if you have the right people helping
you it's doable at the same time when
these companies sell their hardware
product and energy their country they
are good because they can do government
projects and other things but when they
think about going to like another
country right especially developing
countries that country would also need
to buy their own countries kind of
hardware for energy right so to export
you have to you can't go and say like
well my hardware piece is better than
your country one you have to tell them
like a unique value adding point which
is usually like a total solution right
you have to almost a like if you work
with us you get smart grid all together
then like other countries start to like
look at you so if you have the right
partnership in the hardware side within
Korea that you are the software company
you have a great chance to go with them
as part of that total solution that's
what we're trying to work on that's a
great opportunity right so it'll take
care of a lot of your marketing and
sales and you know distribution I'm
afraid we're out of time before we go I
want to say thanks to the Allen minor
foundation for support of our series and
also to the idea space foundation from
Manila for support of this series I'm
happy that Earl can be back with us
again this week so please enjoy the
networking that we have now we can talk
about this informally that's the value
of actually being here so thanks
everyone thanks to our speakers
you